for the first time ever a federal water
shortage has been declared for lake mead
this means cuts will be happening for
states relying on the reservoir joe
mohler begins our team coverage
explaining the push now to conserve joe
brian as the drought continues and the
water levels do drop federal officials
are now shedding light on the growing
problem and then one of these problems
the solutions to them is to conserve
water like at this home here in las
vegas they switched out uh their lawn
for a fake lawn like this and they are
now wanting other people to do their
part
in just five years of that drought
lake snead and powell
lost 50 percent of their capacity
as the historic drought continues in the
colorado river basin a federal water
shortage is announced jacqueline gold
with the lower colorado basin regions to
help mitigate the effects of this
drought
in the meanwhile we are working hard to
implement every action possible to
protect lake mead from reaching
critical elevations
lake mead is at record low levels
dropping below 1075 feet above sea level
the federal shortage means cuts for
states relying on the colorado river
water supply arizona will see a delivery
reduction of about 18
nevada's reduction will be seven percent
and mexico's reduction will be about
five percent with that eighteen percent
cut arizona will feel this the worst
specifically farmers in that state in
nevada it is a different story a lot of
the landscapers right now are usually
backed out about uh i would say anywhere
from three to five months richard torres
owns nb landscapes he says the calls for
turf are constant i would say about five
to eight calls a day
people are interested in solely just
fake grass
nearly half of the water usage in
southern nevada is residential use its
actions like changing yards that have
led to so much conservation for that
reason the federal water cuts to nevada
will not impact delivery because we
already use less than we get taurus says
people are eager to do their part more
people are more interested in fake turf
especially since the southern valley of
water 30 bumped up their rebate to three
dollars
now back out here live the bureau of
reclamation warns of more cuts happening
if these drought conditions do worsen
and lake levels do continue to drop the
southern nevada water authority
meanwhile is still pushing people to
conserve as much water as possible
reporting live in las vegas joe moore 8
news now